[Applaudissements]
problème il y en a un qui va beaucoup
moins se marrer je vous le dis parce que
jean michel vous savez que je pouvais
pas laisser passer ça aujourd'hui ça
l'est pour vous jean michel il ya deux
dates importantes ensuite il ya la
journée mondiale de l'échangisme et ya
le 3 novembre le jour de votre
anniversaire
eh oui si ton et fait 1 3 novembre que
le petit jean michel mr a vu le jour le
3 novembre
1821 jean michel maire aujourd'hui je
n'ai pas de surprise pour vous ah j'ai
laissé jean marc s'occuper de la
surprise
jean-marc je crois que vous avez une
surprise pour jean michel bayle oui
alors je me suis demandé longtemps
qu'est ce qu'ils pouvaient faire plaisir
à un vieux pervers il est vrai une
grande discussion avec moi même j'ai
trouvé une danse sexy hot sexy sexy quoi
alors on va on va revenir au coin
staline chaise impôts bonjour michel
rené souplesse au prince édouard si on
peut installer lâchait s'il vous plaît
merci
mettez-vous là à mettre mettez la au
milieu merci merci il va s'asseoir
jean-michel mère aviva temps forts on y
joue donc vous avez une surprise pour
jean michel maire à ce qu allez-vous
jean-michel voile alors tu vas kiffer
alors
skiff déjà donc vous avez une surprise
pour jean michel seydoux qui l'annoncé
bah si tu veux le faire jean marc à
l'effet papy bassil a surpris
[Applaudissements]
ça
m
la connais pas mais c'est l'anniversaire
de jean michel maire c'était la surprise
à m'en aller et quoi président michel et
voilà sur 22 ans michel
[Applaudissements]
après l'abordage
jamais je suis les étoiles
[Applaudissements]
jodoin de voir la créature de doha